هي الاولى منذ بدء الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا زياره خاطفه وغير معلنه قاده
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الى كييف اجتمع
هناك بعدد من كبار الوزراء الاوكرانيين
وزاره رفقه الرئيس فولو
التذكاريه لقتل الحرب في ساحه كييف اين
اطلقت سفارات الانذار اثناء الزياره لم
يحضر الرجل بيد فارغه فها هو يتعهد بحزمه
مساعدات جديده قدرها 500 مليون دولار
من 700 دبابه والاف المركبات المدرعه والف
نظام مدفعي واكثر من مليوني ذخيره مدفعيه
واكثر من 50 نظاما متقدما لاطلاق الصواريخ
وانظمه مضاده للسفن والدفاع الجوي كل هذا
للدفاع عن اوكرانيا ناهيك عن نصف مليار
دولار اضافيه نعلنها لكم اليوم وغدا
يؤكد بايدن انه سيتم اعلان عقوبات اضافيه
على النخب والشركات التي تحاول التهرب من
العقوبات وتدعم اله الحرب الروسيه اما
الرئيس الاوكراني فبدا سعيدا ومبتهجا
بزياره بايدن التي وصفها بالدعم
الاستراتيجي لجميع الاوكرانيين رجل دعت
ستظهر نتائج هذه الزيارات بالتاكيد في
ساحه المعركه عبر دعم جنودنا وتحرير
اراضينا وقد وضع قرار منح الولايات
المتحده دبابات ابرامز لاوكرانيا الاساس
للتحالفنا ومن المهم التقدم خطوه نحو
الامام في مجال الدفاع الجوي وتلك الاسلحه
هي جندي الدفاع الاول الذي يحمي مدننا
وهذا حقا تعزيز اساسي لمنظومه العسكريه
جاءت زياره بعيدا الى كييف بعد زيارات
عديده لبعض القاده الاوروبيين الى العاصمه
الاوكرانيه وبعد زياره زيلينس كيلي واشنطن
شهر ديسمبر الفائت